bonsoir bertrand le grand merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
alors on change un petit peu de main sur
la vaccination en tout cas
temporairement et par la force des
choses la commande je cite un de la
semaine du 8 mars est exceptionnellement
ouverte aux seuls pharmaciens fait
savoir la direction générale de la santé
vous faites partie des médecins en
colère ce soir la colère c'est un mot un
peu faible en fait en réalité on a
déclenché ce week-end la mobilisation
générale des médecins généralistes dans
les centres de vaccination on à
décongeler des doses qui était prévu
pour une nouvelle nos patients qu'on
avait priorisé et on les a injecté au
premier arrivé premier servi
et maintenant on nous dit que les doses
pour nos patients qu'on avait priorisé
qui en ont besoin pour survivre et pour
éviter de passer en réanimation
cela même ne rompt pas leur droit à leur
vaccination parce que on a décrété que
des pharmaciens auraient un flacon
par-ci par-là soi disant aux derniers
mails de la dgs parce que le nombre de
doses service certes cette semaine là
n'est pas suffisant pour en servir à
chaque médecin
on nage dans l'ubuesque on va nous
interdire de vacciner des patients à
risque pour vacciner n'importe quel
patient qui a accès à internet c'est
inacceptable la colère des médecins
généralistes et sans fin sans fin en
quoi c'est totalement inacceptable
on voit nos patients pour qui on a
choisi de faire le vaccin parce qu'on
veut les sauver d'une maladie grave du
coc vide se fait reprendre leur tour par
des gens qui arrivent en centre de
vaccination
juste parce qu'ils sont éligibles à ce
qu'a été un problème politique donc on
est en train de faire de la politique
spectacle
au lieu de faire de la médecine c'est
inacceptable bertrand c'est vrai qu'on a
du mal je me cache pas nous même temps
j'ai tenté de lire voilà les choses sur
la logistique le calendrier commence
assez fait un petit peu au dernier
moment parce qu'on a du mal à imaginer
que des médecins généralistes soient
obligés de décommander de déprogrammer
des patients et que cela tombe aussi
soudainement et bien vous êtes surpris
et nous sommes les premiers surpris
la décongélation des doses de ce
week-end pour l'opération de
communication politique de notre premier
de notre ministre de la santé ne s'est
pas fait en concertation avec les
médecins
on nous a pas demandé le nombre de doses
qu'on ne s'y fallait prendre alors que
ces mêmes doses étaient planifiés et on
a cru à un moment donné que tout à coup
on avait touché à un grand nombre de
doses qu'on n'était plus en pénurie
et il s'avère en réalité que non nous
avons toujours nous sommes toujours en
pénurie mais qu'on a simplement des
voiliers ces doses pour une opération de
communication politique qui sert de
contre-feu à la première à une
problématique qui est en france
l'absence de doses
et voilà c'est juste ça et aujourd'hui
nous médecins médecins généralistes on
planifie les vaccinations quinze jours
avant parce que on doit sélectionner nos
patients c'est quelque chose que les
français doivent comprendre on n'a pas
assez de doses pour vacciner toutes les
personnes éligibles donc dans ma liste
de 800 personnes que je devrais vacciner
je sélectionne les 150 plus un risque
que je vais vacciner en premier et après
les suivant et ainsi de suite
hélas ce qu'on dit c'est que le
pharmacien qui n'a aucune connaissance
de la de la suite de cette liste va
vacciner le premier arrivé et donc du
coup le patient qui peut être en
position 400 chez moi va se retrouver
avant le positionnant le patient en
position 2 sans quoi donc c'est pas
possible c'est inacceptable c'est
inhumain c'est voit la ccimn éthique
nous ça ça botte tout le travail qu'on a
fait en amont alors dans le même temps
il yal astrazeneca qui ne trouvent pas
toujours preneur on a eu des médecins
voilà qui nous ont expliqué ça sur cette
chaîne la semaine dernière qu'ils
avaient de la stratégie et que tout le
monde on voulait pas ça ne va pas
nécessairement peut-être s'arranger avec
l'épisode autrichien la suspension de ce
vaccin après deux morts suspectes et y
est en tout cas à une injection cas quel
est votre sentiment là dedans c'est vrai
qu'on semble nager
en dans l'absurde dans cette campagne de
vaccination en permanence à bas la vie
le dernier mais de dgs franchement
personne ne pouvait imaginer une telle
absurdité
ça vaudra une démission du directeur de
la dgs s'est fait assez évident
aujourd'hui se dépêtre là dedans pour ce
qui est de la difficulté à placer un
vaccin ou un autre l'intérêt personnel
des patients à risque c'est de se faire
vacciner le plus vite plus importe le
vaccin on sait très bien que n'importe
lequel des trois vaccins a exactement la
même le même bénéfice individuel la
difficulté qu'on a nous en tant que
médecin généraliste c'est d'un point de
vue santé publique ça irait plus vite si
on utilisait les deux vaccins les deux
vaccins arm donc moderna et files or
pour atteindre une immunité collective
mais cette immunité collective on va
l'atteindre aux alentours de septembre
octobre si on a beaucoup de chance donc
là c'est pas la question du moment pour
nos patients pour nos patients la
question c'est de sauver leur peau dans
une troisième vague et ses musiques
question donc après quel que soit le
vaccin on va l'utiliser et on a très peu
de refus en réalité on a 33 mille
médecins généralistes sur cinquante
mille médecins généralistes qui se sont
investis dans la vaccination
astrazeneca et on a en trois jours
injecter plus de doses
quand trois semaines de centre de
vaccination donc le vrai rouleau
compresseur c'est nous et on est en
train de nous arrêter pour masquer
l'absence de commandes de doses de
médecins de vaccins pour les médecins
généralistes donc la france est en
retard et elle continue son retard on
comprend votre agacement parce que c'est
vrai qu'à eu beaucoup de communication
surtout ce week end avec les 250000
injection vendredi 200 milles samedi on
nous dit que voilà ça va monter en
puissance 3 7 millions français qui ont
reçu au moins une dose de vaccin on nous
dit toujours que c'est voilà tel ou tel
pour cent de plus que la dernière fois
sauf que quand on regarde les chiffres
évidemment à l'étranger notamment au
royaume-uni 1 15 7% des personnes contre
5,6 pour cent de la population française
on communique beaucoup mais on est tout
de même parmi les derniers de la classe
c'est une politique du dernier de la
classe
et c'est une politique qui n'est pas
transparente faut dire
choses comme elles sont aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans un échec de la vaccination
nos personnes de plus de 75 ans qui
souffre notre cible prioritaire ne sont
même pas majoritairement vacciner alors
même qu avec le noël nombre de doses 90
% des anglais été vaccinées à doses à
nombre de doses égale donc quelle que
soit la manière dont on regarde les
choses que ce soit sur la vitesse
d'exécution qui a été bien meilleures en
angleterre que ce soit sur le
pourcentage de patients vaccinés
patients à risque la france a échoué à
tous les niveaux et c'est l'échec de la
rsc l'échec des de la dgs et c'est
l'échec du ministre dans le déploiement
de la vaccination
et tout cela est en train de subir une
opération de communication politique
pour faire porter ça sur des médecins
libéraux qui n'ont strictement rien
demandé là dedans ils ne font que leur
travail
donc c'est vraiment vraiment très
énervant alors mis le tout savamment ou
des mots vaccinodromes à on voulait pas
le faire mais finalement on fait comme
comme les allemands une petite réaction
là dessus aussi
c'est toujours la même c'est on est en
france donc non plus dans une politique
gaulliste de protection des plus faibles
on est dans une politique du premier
arrivé premier servi
c'est le libéralisme que l'on déteste et
même nous en tant que médecin libéral on
déteste ce type de choses là c'est une
chose ou on ne donne pas la priorité aux
personnes qui le nécessitent
on donne la priorité à celui qui a le
temps de prendre son rendez vous sur
internet ou qui a les moyens de le
prendre
ça va pas merci beaucoup en tout cas
bertrand legrand d'avoir été avec nous
nous avoir exprimé votre colère après
donc cette décision des autorités de
transférer en tout cas les vaccins pour
le moment où pharmaciens merci
à vous